Frances president and men while macaroni
is hosting the one planet summit today
in Paris focusing on climate change
president Trump was not invited in his
first and only American network TV
interview macron talked to the CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Glor about his
relationship with President Trump
Jerusalem and climate change how often
do you speak to the president Ron Luke
as often as we need for instance during
the past weeks really we had probably
three to four phone calls together we
have very fluent and open discussion and
you would characterize that relationship
is friendly yes very direct you talked
about Jerusalem
yes exactly before yes and he said what
it say that probably it will announce
the fact that he wanted to broken eyes
arisen as cattle of his role and you
told him what I told him I I thought it
was it was a mistake because we work and
we've worked all together on the
recognition of two states Israel and
Palestine with borders recognized by the
international community and that such a
unilateral decision is not compliant
with our international discussions and
international rules and will not
facilitate a peace process because
that's a unilateral decision and that's
pretty much in leading for the
Palestinian side was that a was that a
calm conversation was that a
confrontational conversation I think
it's always an open and direct
discussion you can agree to disagree
which is the case between us on some
some issues the United States will
withdraw from the Paris climate Accord I
was elected to represent the citizens of
Pittsburgh not Paris President Trump
says it's bad news because it's bad for
the American workers bad for American
people you I disagree that what he means
what he wants to say expressing this
this point it's it's it's bad for
American workers it's just to see I will
have to close old plans call activities
and all the stuff I mean it's true
you will have to switch from a model to
another one but I mean it's
understandable not to deal with reality
and what we know what we have to protect
these people not jobs if you want to
protect people you retrain them you help
them in order to change their jobs to
new ones much more adapted and
consistent with our commitments and our
collective interests why do you think
the president pulled out of this first
of all he was elected by by you guys and
as the president of Z the American
people and secondly took a commitment
during his campaign I had a lot of
discussion with him we have a very good
personal relationship and I do believe
it's important to have on board the US
government and all the Americans but I
do respect him and I do respect this
decision so I am NOT saying he doesn't
understand and doesn't share the
analysis but just it took a political
commitment how much has the withdrawal
affected your efforts I think the
withdraw to be totally fair with you
created a huge momentum to me to create
a counter momentum I launched the same
day of the announcement of the present
firm's decision to leave Paris agreement
I took an initiative called make up on
that great again it creates a huge
mobilization of a lot of countries
saying I do confirm and you had right
after the US announcement an
acceleration of the ratification process
in a lot of countries so just one letter
saying you say you're in better shape
now because of this withdrawal that the
president favor demanding because I
think we have two phenomenon so
withdrawal of the US which for me is a
mistake but it creates an impulse for a
lot of others to say okay we have to
react and do something because it's
impossible to leave the floor to a sort
of dismantling of the Paris agreement
second a deep wake-up call for the
private sectors and some of us to say
wow so we have to react otherwise
basically it will become a little bit
shaky just think one sec that if we
decide not to decide if we decide not to
move and not change
our way to produce to invest to behave
de facto we decide you decide to
condemned billions of people in the
coming decades that's a big decision and
we will I mean all of us will be judged
for that Jeff Glor is full interview
with the French president will be airing
today on our streaming network cbsn